I did not email any classified material
to anyone there is no classified
material 110 emails in 52 email chains
have been determined by the owning
agency to contain classified information
at the time they were sent or received I
provided all my emails that could
possibly be work-related several
thousand work-related emails that were
not among the group of 30,000 emails
returned by Secretary Clinton I thought
using one device would be simpler she
also used numerous mobile devices to
send and to read email there were no
security breaches it is possible that
hostile actors gained access to
secretary Clinton's personal email
account it was my practice to
communicate with State Department and
other government officials on their
dot-gov accounts the hostile actors
gained access to the private commercial
email accounts of people with whom
Secretary Clinton was in regular contact
from her personal account no doubt that
we've done exactly what we should have
done they were extremely careless in
their handling of very sensitive highly
classified information people will be
able to judge for themselves we cannot
find a case that would support bringing
criminal charges on these facts thank
you thank you
to be clear this is not to suggest that
in similar circumstances a person who
engaged in this activity would face no
consequences Americans will find that
too you know interesting and I look
forward to having a discussion about
them